[Musique]
une grande carcasse de pierre est
rentrée en plein cœur de Saint-Laurent
l'abbaye à l'abandon témoigne de l'un
des plus grands monastères d'univers
au 6e siècle il a connu un âge d'or
avant d'être progressivement démantelé
et atteint par les ravages du temps des
guerres et des pillages de 1945 à 1980
il reste à l'air libre avec l'eau le gel
qui pénètre et qui qui déstabilise
encore les maçonneries et puis à partir
des années 80 il y a un travail de
consolidation dont on voit ici les
éléments mais qui nécessitent d'être
complètement repris et on a bien
évidemment un bâtiment qui reste fragile
malgré les étaient encore en place
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
lorsque le clocher de l'église
s'effondre en 1945 entraînant une partie
du transept la sauvegarde devient
compromise impossible pour la commune
d'un peu plus de 200 habitants de
financer de telles réparations
nous avions la seule capacité d'éviter
qu'il se détériore trop vite
soit en refaisant des petits morceaux de
toiture sans consolidant des scellement
de pierre mais pas quelque chose de
durable très longtemps dans le temps
mais aujourd'hui une nouvelle vient
bouleverser le long des labrement un don
de plus d'un million d'euros les gays en
mai dernier par Jeanne potteras
passionné de l'abbaye et décédé à 150 à
condition que l'argent soit dédié à la
restauration du site
est extrêmement rare on ne connaissait
pas et puis c'était une ruine qui était
considérée comme perdue la déterminé
complètement en une et cette partie de
la demande et là évidemment un jour
nouveau arrive il va y avoir une
possibilité avec un tel démarrage
le montant ne suffira pas à financer
entièrement le projet mais il va
permettre de lancer le chantier les
études devront déterminer l'ampleur des
travaux sur les différents bâtiments la
possibilité de reconstruire en partie la
flèche
pour redonner vie à un ensemble
architectural qui a su conserver des
trésors bien cachés comme cette
charpente du bâtiment principal
c'est un édifice qui est qui est
remarquable qui est oubliée et que nous
essayons par nos diverses actions de
de faire revivre
[Musique]
préserver un morceau d'histoire c'est
aussi ce qui a attiré la Fondation pour
la sauvegarde de l'art français dans un
tel projet elle apporte son expertise
administrative juridique et fiscale plus
qu'une simple reconstruction
l'association veut y voir une
opportunité des édifices de cette
importance sont souvent considérés comme
une charge alors qu'on est convaincu à
la sauvegarde de la France et tout
association de défense du patrimoine que
ces édifices sont réellement une chance
pour la commune parce que ça va générer
du tourisme lorsque ce sera rénové que
ça va créer du lien et que c'est une
chance inouïe qui est en fait ici devant
nos yeux et qu'on a trop souvent oublié
il faudra encore patienter quelques mois
avant de voir le chantier débuter
et que le leg de Jeanne potteras permet
de réconcilier saint-laurent-l'abbaye
avec son passé
[Musique]